thank you for having me I feel like this
is like the warmest welcome I've ever
seen it is a very warm welcome but it's
a warm place I have to say it's you can
come in here in any mood and it'll like
lift you up maybe not to Douglas hi
Douglas oh my gosh I love your shoes
thank you wait a minute your 23rd
birthday is coming up yeah
um and um do you have any birthday
Traditions oh okay so my favorite family
birthday tradition is that we make
birthday shirts of the birthday person
where we'll just wear that person's face
on our chest all day for their birthday
but it doesn't say happy birthday or
anything so it just looks like we're
massive fans of whoever we're with I
love that now I had mentioned in uh the
break that there's a possibility that
you believe in love at first sight okay
I have to give full credit to my parents
because they have the best story and I
remember hearing this growing up and in
Minnesota
my mother's out with some of her friends
my father's out with some of their
friends and she turns the corner and
goes oh my God that's my husband what
says it out loud and catches herself
they've never met before like have not
spoken she does not know who he he is
ends up later that night not talking but
getting a picture of him like a proper
photo photo of him yeah and then uh
friends would come over and look through
the phone book to see if they could
figure out who this was and finally
finally I'll fast forward through some
of the details but when they get in
touch you know he actually lists
everything she had on that night like oh
you know of course I remember you you
were wearing and then Liz what she was
wearing
and there's just something about that
meat cute where they both noticed each
other and did not speak I loved that
because it's sort of I do believe in
that and I believe in that oh God what
oh god sorry sorry I am so sorry Douglas
you're out of here
come here
come here I am so so sorry
[Applause]
and my goodness is not just so
embarrassing
um okay
um they're inspired uh do you believe
that people will go to Great Lengths to
find each other I mean I hope it's true
I'm in my mid-20s I'm hoping that that's
how it works are you single I am I am
too
do you want to date
see I don't I don't know me neither I
don't know
I like meeting people
and then the other thing is I just got
out of a relationship so I'm just kind
of you know I'm a big commitment person
it was three years so I don't even know
what to do with myself I'm just taking
some me time my friends and I are
calling it selfish season
I like that
um now grownish just got picked up for
season six and I mean this season the
character and you are paralleling in
that you're going to college yeah so I
mean what's cool is I've played Zoe for
nine years and she's always been a year
older than me but the one thing about
the pandemic and not being able to shoot
our season right away is that we were
finally the same age when we shot this
season which was real like life imitates
art and then this season which also
mirrors my life she's back on campus
Because her brother's at school and it's
really cool because my brother's a
junior at UCLA and so that is the
relationship we have of now being too
like semi-adults or entering adulthood
and me trying to figure out how to be a
big sister or how to be a good big
sister with with advice to offer me
having my siblings like they're the best
it's just it's so important to me wait
is it true that you have a black belt in
karate I do what where does it end with
you it's you're so amazing I did this
before College though so that wasn't at
the same time wait but seriously you do
a karate you do karate you have a black
belt you got yourself into Harvard and
you're a voting rights advocate
thank you I mean look at who I'm seeing
across from what are you talking the
woman who brought her dogs each other on
stage
now
[Music]